I think we've done fairly well actually
on Turing in nagamma all this kind of
thing we've raced around Bletchley parks
or the Colossus machine which was for
the tourney or Lawrence cipher there is
a bit missing in the middle
why was Colossus necessary why did they
need a computer what was the nature of
that traffic that Colossus could help
with in one of our previous videos we've
actually shown a picture of this weird
trace that they were getting off the
airwaves they showed it to the experts
at Bletchley Park and they said that's
broadcast teleprinter traffic and we
remind ourselves they may not have had
electronic computers back in the 1940s
early on but they certainly didn't have
teleprinter machines they were very
common used in stock exchanges used for
foreign telegrams all fours
it looks a bit like a keyboard as you
press the keys there was a very
comforting splash splash splash sound of
the electromechanical things because as
well as sending five or maybe even seven
whole pulses over the lab line it was
also printing out as you went what it
was you were typing so that technology
was just phenomenally well known the
staff at Blessed Park were comforting in
a way that it was teleprinter traffic
but puzzled as to its precise nature
however they'd all been on cryptography
training courses and and they or or even
been instructors on cryptography
training courses and one of the stories
was don't forget the Vernon cipher so
again in a previous video there's more
details about this but a guy called Vern
amo worked for Bell Labs AT&T in the
late 20s early 30s had this idea of
taking five whole teleprinter codes and
exclusive oaring them with an arbitrary
letter which was like a cipher key and
coming out with a different letter I'll
just do one for you just to remind you
of the sort of
suppose that went on probably available
somewhere online code-breaking with a
closest computer in the teleprinter code
the letter h is represented by 0 0 1 0 1
now if you take the letter F that is 1 0
1 1 0 and from numerous videos we've
done about the nature of bitwise
exclusive or is now dead easy exclusive
or says you do it bitwise it is like an
addition but what happens is the result
is 1 if and only if the two bits differ
if they're the same then the answer is 0
so 0 exclusive order 1
they're different that's a 1 0 with 0
they're the same it's a 0 1 with 1
they're the same it's answers a 0 0 with
1 is 1 1 with 0 is 1 the result then of
exclusive o-ring F with H is to give you
a cipher result of 1 0 0 1 1 you'd have
known this off by heart if you were at
Bletchley Park in middle Fortis but I
don't know it off by heart by the answer
is that is the letter B Burnham said
that's that's a great idea if I provide
a paper tape with a key on it that's
random I'll just you know randomizing
myself now type in a great long random
key stream if you exclusive or these 5
bit patterns with each other and the
other tape is the plaintext top secret
message you want to send then finest a
superb way of encrypting it using
believe it or not Virna minh bell labs
actually patented this but there's one
huge problem in getting it to work
because their idea was you have a 5 hole
paper tape full of your plaintext your
secret text you wanna send you have a
gilbert vernon produced equivalent tape
with lots of random and you just want to
run them side by side through some
machine that reads that one reads that
one exclusive ORS them and prints out
the encrypted result and what's the
problem if you
truly used to paper tapes keeping them
in sync they had huge difficulties with
differential slippage so you either
ended up with them not in line and not
working at all or the wrong pattern bin
excellence of order the wrong pattern so
in the end the feeling I think was among
the cryptographic community this is a
promising technique but there's no way
you want to be trying to synchronize to
stretchy bits of tape one bit of tape
fine even keep trying
so there was a knowledge in the cipher
world that sooner or later somebody
would produce the key stream not on
another tape but automatically as part
of the teleprinter process you could
have a bolt on accessory to a
teleprinter that provided the 5 bit key
stream automatically either
electronically or electromechanical II
and so this one that has become so
famous which the Allies Bletchley called
Tunney part of these fishy ciphers they
didn't know what machine was producing
it and our colleague Jack copeland
historian and his on top of all these
things says every time you mentioned
this you must mention that at Bletchley
Park if you called it Lawrence in 1941
they wouldn't have known what you were
talking about the company that made the
machine that did this traffic was a
mystery to them they just called it
Tunney it wasn't just the mystery Tunney
machine there were other machines around
I have to emphasize this there was a
haggled in cipher machine in Sweden
there was a Siemens cipher machine a lot
of people were investigating this idea
of providing the keystream
electromechanical II and not on a
separate tape so the overall picture
then of exclusive inge oaring teletype
characters the plane takes one with a
key character and doing it character by
character by character by character you
could summarize it by saying that the
ciphertext
that you prepare is a result of taking a
plain text and remember the plus in a
circle means exclusive all so that's
your basic equation cipher text is plain
text exclusive Ord character by
character with the key stream like that
now we did a thing called zig zag
decryption which you can look and you
can see the details of that can a long
story short the Allies were very lucky
in that by using this special zigzag
decryption on a rather weak message they
got a whole bunch of key out of it and
this was that Goldust in the so-called
research section of Bletchley
headed up by a guy called Jerry Morgan
picked on a new recruit called Bill
taught he was from Cambridge just like
cheering but I empathize who built
because he started off doing chemistry
and had it been today he'd have moved
into computer science but as it was then
he gradually turned himself into a
mathematician he loved doing puzzles he
went through his Bletchley pre-training
learnt all about vernon's and whatever
and they put him working on another cog
a machine called haggling machine which
was used for Italian ciphers it turned
out to be rather simpler than tourney
and it was good training for him they'd
got tons of stuff from this mystery
machine which was defying analysis bill
Tut was given the chance to make a name
for himself by having a go at it the
only extra information that Jerry Morgan
gave him was the following he said do
you know the Germans just like we
encountered on the Enigma in the very
early days are actually sending us the
initial settings before we got these
4000 characters the Germans sent out
what we are calling the indicator and
it's passed into Fame and infamy the
indicator I always pronounce it to
myself as H quid Peck see see Mike what
you'll find in the literature is people
don't want to say it
it's called Zed mug rosy mug whichever
side of the Atlantic
Iran and with my mid-atlantic persona
please forgive me for switching from one
to the other just like that so Z Mugsy
bug was the indicator setting at which
they had this lucky break and could get
the key Morgan said so built Hut he said
you know the weird thing is we've looked
at these settings are always alphabetic
and if we're assuming that it's a bit
live haggling there's lots of teeth on
there and there and all this kind of
stuff
they're only ever using 25 letters
except in one of these positions
remember which it was now I think it's
the fifth one along in that position
there's only ever 23 alphabetic letters
we've saved up all the indicators we
were had and on that position they only
use 23 letters out of 26 so with his
training in mind built up said 23 is a
prime number
interesting I wonder if a bit like the
haggling machine this thing is actually
using cog wheels on each of the
bitstreams five parallel bit streams of
a five bit character perhaps it's using
different wheels or different streams
and messing about that way with the
patterns of once and series that gets
exclusive odd you know as part of the
key generation it's from small thing I
wonder if this is a cogs machine if
there's a 23 to but then the rest of our
25 right 23 times 25 is 575 yeah let's
start investigating now think of this
stage before we get stuck into what
built up did we need to talk about
possibilities of repetitions depending
on the number of cog wheels you've got
let me put it to you like this suppose
you have two very simple cog wheels
indeed so simple they'd never ever be
used in cryptography but in some sense
these these things are on a common
spindle
like that and every time that rotates it
moves on one position in fact I'll use a
red pen I'm saying that this first wheel
has only got two possible positions it
can either be there or it can be there
there's a rod if you like flipping from
being up right there to up right down
there this one the fact that it looks
like the mercedes-benz logo is purely
coincidental this one that's got three
possible positions let's call these two
positions on the two tooth wheel a and B
those are the two possible positions on
the car logo whatever that brand is I
don't know let's just call it 1 2 & 3
the start position we can characterize
as being a 1 then we click the spindle
and it moves on to the next stop
position a will turn into pointing
downwards are being be the one on the
other hand on the other one we'll just
go to 2 so you get a 1 B 2 or more click
B will go back to a but 2 will go to 3 a
3 one more click you'll go from A to B
again but the 3 will go back to 1 B will
go back to a again 1 will go to 2
a will go back to B again two will go to
3 and finally back to hey what may not
look relevant but it is this is looking
for repeats when does a pattern repeat
and it depends on the number of teeth on
the wheel so one looks at this and you
think alright a 1 how long before it
comes back to being a 1 1 2 3 4 5 6
oh what a coincidence we've got a
two-position wheel we've got a position
wheel 3 times 2 is 6 it sees a instant
mathematics it's obvious that the case
that all you do is multiply the number
of teeth together nope even Shawn
shaking his head not quite causation
correlation causation and correlation
yes those of you who are numberphile
fans this is trivial stuff you know it
off backwards but for those who are less
familiar let's just now develop it one
stage further and be the devil's
advocate but this time we'll turn
the motorized logo into being a cross
shape it's a four position cog here and
I'll number it one two three four now
since I've done this earlier I'll write
out the sequence for you as to what
happens here it goes a 1 B 2 1 2 a 3 1 2
B 4 and back to a 1 so what's the repeat
length 4 but look there's 4 on that is
true on that it ought to be 8 why isn't
a date why is it only four and the
answer is there are factors in common
this is 2 that is 4 4 is not a prime
number is 2 times 2 so the factor of 2
is it is a common base like doing lowest
common denominators in you know when
you're combining fractions you try and
find out what's the thing on the bottom
that's got everything in it but it is as
small as possible and that is what is
happening here you don't want cogwheels
with factors in common because otherwise
your repeat length will be a lot shorter
than you ever imagined finally I'll just
draw out the possibility for you will do
a 3 with a 4 and they now got a B C 1 2
3 4 what is the overall length of the
repeat cycle and the answer is it's 12
and you say 4 times 3 is 12 before isn't
prime number so why is it working out
okay again that you do just multiply
them the answer is that 3 & 4 are what's
called relatively prime although 4 isn't
a prime number it doesn't have any
factors in common with 3 so therefore
relatively prime sometimes called
co-prime the story will go then on the
numbers of teeth on these wheels we
think in this machine they'll either be
a prime number or if they ran out of
prime numbers and the prior the prime
number of teeth getting a bit big the
next best thing because it is safe is to
use relatively prime
numbers and in the long run we will find
in this thing we're going to talk about
that one of the cogs has got 26 teeth on
it which is not prime but it's 2 times
13 so so long as that has no factors in
common with anything else that's equally
safe so this then was the backdrop of
what they were expecting what built out
was expecting it was that there would be
a machine probably with several cogs in
it of some sort and the prime numbers of
teeth would probably be involved so
remembering what Jerry Morgan had said
to him about this that one of these
positions had only got twenty three
possible alphabetic characters all the
rest had 25 he said okay what about the
product of 23 by 25 there aren't any
factors in common is he 23 prime tell
you what I'll do he said rather than
worrying about a whole character let me
just look at of the leftmost stream of
bits in all these characters now I would
call that bit stream 1 what they did it
bless your part was they call it impulse
1 what I'm talking about is the stream
of bits from all of the characters like
you know the bits in the number one
position overall characters in the
message from one to five left to right
he started off with what he regarded as
bitstream wand the leftmost one
he said remembering my training which
said if you think there's going to be
repeats Apple look for them and he said
well why not do two at once if I do 23
times 25 I might be able to spot
vertical runs happening every 23 if I
write them out in a block I might see
them at 25 because they're not going to
fear they're relatively prime so on an
enormous sheet of paper and it doesn't
matter it's Turing built of a host of
other workers at Bletchley Park they
used acres of big sheets of paper
divided
two squares to make notes on and he said
I wrote it out along a great long strip
575 bits then another 574 then another
phone a sofa and don't forget this
intercept was four thousand characters
so he ended up with six and a half huge
long rows all on this combined period of
has ever and he said I was expecting to
look down vertically and find every
twenty-three there was a bunch of ones
or someone this or every twenty five
those pants didn't see that looked at it
carefully and to my amazement he said as
you look at it I saw going down these
five rows a clear diagonal sequence of
ones going like that but down the
diagonal what did that tell me I've got
the wrong period it wasn't five seven
five it was five seven four
forty one is a factor of five seven four
so he says in his paper if people say
this ingenious built up was straight on
to spotting twenty three and twenty
finest the first thing he found no he
didn't he went off down the wrong trail
temporarily but accidentally which sheer
pure luck found that the number one
stream was having its ones and zeros
that were added to it was generated by a
will probably with a periodicity of 41
but the Germans wouldn't be daft enough
to make sure there's a blindingly
obvious repeat every forty one they'll
be messing about going on behind the
scenes it will be forty one but it will
perhaps be disguised but maybe they
didn't totally succeed in disguising it
enough armed with 41 what he then did
said right I'm gonna write down all of
these sequences now not on a five seven
five grid but on a grid of 41 so he
writes out this impulse stream of ones
and zeros but the tradition of Bletchley
was to use dot for 0 and X for one touch
says he can't understand why the
there's other people say it's all very
well bill for you mathematicians wanting
ones and zeros but I find patterns
easier to spot when dotson crosses I
think I agree actually and when he put
out all these impulses all 4,000 of them
on a grid 41 across you suddenly find
that not on every row but on quite a few
of them there are certain patterns that
repeat so the message from that is yes
there is a wheel with 41 teeth is
involved but there's almost certainly
some extra stage where it's trying to
disguise what's going on it might be
another wheel with different teeth or
something's going on it's not pure and
simple it wouldn't be because it'd be
dead easy to decrypt if it was but there
is a sneaky suspicion 41 was involved so
bill Turk tells the rest there is a
sectional piled in and helped because
what he points out next obvious thing to
do is look at the number two stream look
at the number three stream look at
number four stream nothing number five
stream and when we've worked out what
the initial wheels how many teeth
they've got on then we can take that
away and start looking to see if we can
figure out how the excess stuff that's
trying to distort it gets generated and
to cut a very long story very short
after a few weeks work of probably ten
or eleven people what they finally came
up with was in this diagram here they
decided that initially your stream from
your tele printer was port through five
distinct cogs one for each bit stream or
impulse the numbers of teeth were forty
one thirty one twenty nine twenty six
twenty three so as touch says eventually
if I'd not discovered the forty one I
would have proved what a genius I was
because 23 is there it's just that it's
on stream five not stream one but it is
there right and then they managed to
discover that the obscuring mechanism
was another set of wheels which
sometimes turned on by one place and
sometimes
and these have got 43 47 51 53 and 59
teeth and the eagle-eyed among you who
watch every single morsel of numberphile
will immediately jump on our necks and
say 26 is in prime no it isn't it's 2
times 13 but it's relatively prime to
everything else equally 51 is in prime
is 3 times 17 fine so if you use other
relative prime ministers you can't have
2 or 3 is involved in their factors
because they're taken up now but that
was it these two extra wheels at the
bottom there was another thing they
could sort of understand why 10 wheels
two sets of of fives well what are the
other two do the other two in a very
complicated way determine whether this
second set of wheels moves or stays
still and I think the Germans were
hoping that by that mechanism they would
confuse the Allied decription effort
even more because the first set always
move you do a character worth it'll
click and they all move on but they've
got different numbers of teeth on them
second set sometimes moves sometimes
doesn't by the end of the war the
feeling was from people like Jack good
and Donald Michie who had a look at this
statistically they said you know by the
time you got used to looking for whether
the whales were moving I stutter we call
it you've got to be able to spot the
stutter and it was such a landmark once
you were really familiar with it that
the Germans actually did themselves a
disfavor they'd have been better off not
to put it in they managed to get all of
that structure out of it what they
realized was their next big task was to
say okay we know the number of teeth on
each wheel but what we don't know is the
patterns on the wheels of ones and
zeroes that they are contributing to the
exclusive or key characters so that was
another great long journey because they
knew that all the haggling machine so
it's probably similar on the
tummy machine that on every cog there
was a little slider which could set up
or down and in one position he
contributed a note but if you put it
down if it was contributed or won so can
you imagine going that the task of
setting this wretched thing up you've
got all of these cogs with all these
teeth and if you end up the toner and
teeth of several hundred and every one
of these positions has got to be set up
with a one or a zero according to this
instruction manual do you think they
change them every day not a chance
they only changed the wheel patterns
once a month
you've got the indicator that tells you
what the wheel settings are you can work
for a whole month I'm trying to work out
what the wheel patterns are once you've
got it you can decrypt like mad what
would happen if they ever stopped saying
let's not put the indicator out it only
helps them mad it doesn't help them it's
totally secure but he's pointless to put
it out just like on enigma so in the
middle of early to middle of 1942 they
stopped putting out the indicator oh
dear calamity
and I should caveat this by saying I'm
going to be talking in general terms
each operating system with us Windows
Linux Mac or iOS BSD insert your
favorite operating system here that you
probably